this video is brought to you by
nordvpn give yourself options
online go to nordvpn.com forward slash bio
to get a two-year plan with a huge discount
plus a bonus month and a free
gift more on them in just a bit
today's protagonist was called the highest and
the culminating point that beauty has attained
in the sphere of music or even the musical christ
these options do not come from just any classical
music enthusiast but some guy called tchaikovsky
who knew a thing or two about composition he was
preferring to wolfgang amadeus mozart possibly
the greatest musical genius to ever grace our
ears and souls here at biographics we admit that
we don't necessarily have the knowledge to analyze
in-depth mozart's compositions we will do
our best however to cover his short yet
incredibly eventful life and we'll also
debunk a couple of myths along the way
wolfgang amadeus mozart was born in salzburg
on january 27 1756. he was the seventh child
of anna maria and leopold composer for the local
prince archbishop count schrattenbach since burst
his parents and siblings called him woolfer
the princess bishopric of salzburg was one
of many small sovereign states within the holy
roman empire and an extremely wealthy one the
environment may have been provincial compared to
other large european capitals but arts and music
enjoyed the patronage of the court leopold
soon realized that wolfel was endowed with
an extraordinary musical talent at the age of
three he could play his first pieces on the piano
at four the violin woolfell's sister nanil
displayed similar abilities soon leopold was
dedicating most of his energies to developing
their natural skills the boy appeared to be
the most gifted of the two absorbing musical
theory with much appetite and little effort
under leopold's loving but inflexible guidance
woolfell composed his first piano concerto age
four followed by a minuet and a trio for keyboard
at six in between these two accomplishments the
young mozart discovered the joys of singing and
performing live in 1761 the five-year-old had a
minor role in the musical drama sigismund
king of hungary this first experience of
the theatrical stage may have influenced his
love of opera in later life around this time
leopold realized that salzburg was too small for
wolferl and nanelle the dad became an impresario
and planned a trip to the imperial court in
vienna in october of 1762. emperor francis
the first and empress maria theresa welcomed
the tiny performers at their lavish shamroom
palace maria theresa was astonished at wolfgang's
skills spoiling him with compliments and presence
to express his gratitude the boy jumped on the
empress's lap and kissed her but the emperor
wanted to challenge the boy even further he asked
him to play the piano keys covered by a screen
and then to play using only one finger wolfgang
accepted and won the challenge now a celebrity
the boy became a sort of mascot for the ladies
it caught one day he slipped to the floor while
at courts and an archdust just lifted woolfell to
his feet and he told her you are a dear good lady
and you shall be my wife the good lady was
marie antoinette the future queen of france
leopold had hit upon a winning idea courts
around europe would pay good money to see his
children perform the mozart's continued their
triumville albeit exhausting tour of europe
leopold's tactics may appear akin to exploitation
of child labor but it appears that his children
and especially wolfgang greatly enjoyed their
travels and their performances for the future
composer they were also an occasion to hone
his skills and explore new musical genres
in april 1764 leopold warfare and nana toured
london where the boy prodigy was challenged by
lawyer danes barrington to improvise two arias
in the popular style of italian opera after a
short moment of reflection wolfgang hammered
at the harpsichord delivering both a love song
and a song of rage the anecdote proves how the
young talent could effectively internalize and
reproduce the standard conventions of popular
genres at the time the tour resumed with stops
in flanders france switzerland and salzburg
before the mozart's return to vienna in 1768.
the new emperor joseph ii commissioned the
12-year-old mozart to compose an opera la finta
semleche which attracted the brave italian master
pietro matatacio not bad for a pre-teen but the
hype around the opera attracted the envy of the
imperial entourage due to their scheming the opera
did not reach the stage but leopold and
wolfgang and set their minds on conquering
the operatic world to do so they had to take
by storm the cradle of lyrical theatre italy
in december of 1769 they crossed the alps for a
tour of northern italy where wolfgang continued to
impress audiences with his operatic improvisations
according to a newspaper published in vienna four
verses were submitted to him on which he composed
on the spot on aria in the best taste in the very
act of singing it eventually wolfgang received
another commission for an opera at the age of
14 he saw his mithridates king of ponto opening
in milan to rave reviews the success was quickly
followed by another milanese debut aschiano and
alba the italian tour continued from strength to
strength while in bologna he attended the lessons
of gian batista martini mastering counterpoint or
the art of combining different melodic lines and
musical composition martini was impressed and
he encouraged mozart to take the entrance
exam for the philharmonic society he was
given a musical theme and was instructed to
build a fugue for four instruments around
it a fugue is a composition where a theme is
introduced at the beginning and then repeated
at different pitches half an hour later wolfgang
had completed the composition performed it and
bagged his diploma next stage of the tour rome and
the vatican where wolfgang performed another stunt
he attended a performance of choral work misery
by alegri no printed copies of the composition
existed and the pope himself had forbidden it
from being transcribed but he memorized the
entire score and put it a paper in secret after
the performance the next day he played and sang
it flawlessly to an audience of gasping musicians
he was now the talk of rome although some envious
souls gossip that his talents lay in a magical
ring a sort of talisman that he wore all the time
however our genius simply removed the ring and
proved that he could still rock those ivory keys
no magic involved what a surprise the triumph
was now complete young mozart was granted an
audience with pope clement xiv who appointed
him knight of the order of the golden spur
in the spring of 1772 mozart returned to
salzburg looking for permanent employment
he founded at the court of the new prince
archbishop count colorado who hired him as a
concert master with a rather low salary of 150
gilders the composer was not over the moon yet
these were productive years the musician penned
further operas and his first piano concerto he
also perfected his technique as he studied the
works of joseph hayden and the imperial court
composer antonio celieri now let's take a quick
break here antonio celieri is remembered by most
as the patron saint of mediocrity a fashionable
composer whose work did not stand the test of
time consumed by jealousy who was embroiled in
a bit of rivalry against mozart a feud which
resulted in salieri accelerating mozart's
death at least that's the plot of the film
amadeus by milosh forman which is based on the
play by peter schaefer inspired by a previous
work of alexander pushkin and it was all based
on unfounded gossip i'll get to this later but
rest assured that the two composers largely
respected each other and that our friend antonio
never killed anybody in 1777 the only one who had
a beef with mozart was his employer count colorado
unappreciative of his compositions and operating
on a tight budget the prince of salzburg laid
off his constant master now age 21 mozart set off
on a new voyage in search of patronage this time
his father had to stay and work in salzburg
so mum anna maria was to accompany the musical
marvel so how would wolfgang fare without
leopold's invasive yet steadying influence
in 1777 and 1778 wolfgang and mum saw work
in augsburg munich and mannheim but work
remained elusive there are many reasons for
this first wolfgang had grown into a playful
yet overconfident young man a confidence which
bordered on arrogance he lacked the diplomacy to
function in an aristocratic court and spoke his
mind to wealthy patrons this resulted in being
snubbed in favor of more accommodating rivals
the second reason is the mozart was going through
a massive composer's block in 1777 and 1778
he wrote to his father that he was working on
numerous projects and that he and anna maria were
living like royalty to the point that he had grown
slightly fat but not as fat as the fib he was
telling his dad the musician was going through
exceptional difficulties in writing new pieces for
example in late 1777 mozart had been commissioned
for three flute concertos by a dutch patron he
soon got stuck urged by his father to honour the
contract mozart simply retrieved a previous
work and oboe concerto and changed the solo
part to that of a flute but he delivered only two
out of the three concertos and he had to forfeit
the payment of 200 guilders mozart's flute gate
debunks the myth that the composer could crank
out new music easily and could devise new works in
his head before transcribing them without revision
or afterthought the myth originates from a letter
attributed to mozart published by magazine editor
johann roschlitz decades after his death the whole
piece though it be long stands almost finished and
completed my mind so that i can survey it like
a fine picture or a beautiful statue at a glance
so mozart's music came from a higher plane and
reached his mind fully formed through a stroke
of divine inspiration except no it didn't the
letter was a forgery the secret to mozart's genius
was constant practice study revision more study
and more practice even if he conceived as main
themes in his head mozart still had to sit at the
keyboard to refine them work out their variations
and orchestrations a long mind-shattering process
which day after day was bound to cause mental
fatigue by his own admission mozart struggled
the most with string quartets when writing an
orchestral piece for example he would first create
the main theme for the main treble instrument
next he nailed the bass lines and finally the
inner parts and orchestrations but when tackling
a quartet he wrote the four parts at the same time
baa baa baar placing a great deal of effort in
building a complex counterpoint this is what made
him sweat the most wolfgang amadeus mozart was an
exceptionally talented and hardworking human but
he was a human after all and as any other 21 year
old he was prone to another source of distraction
after germany anna maria and wolfgang were due to
visit versailles the trip was thwarted when mozart
met the first great love of his life the young and
beautiful singer aloisia weber he followed her in
a tour to the hague and even supported her family
financially to leopold's concern dad sent anamaria
to retrieve him and finally the two set off for
paris but their french experience was a terrible
one they were expecting to be welcomed at court
but all mozart could find were some teaching jobs
and he could only afford a rather sleazy hotel
as they spiraled into poverty anna maria fell ill
and eventually died on the third of july 1778. all
right we'll get back to our video in just a second
but first here's a word from today's video sponsor
nordvpn look everybody uses the internet slightly
differently and that's totally fine but you don't
want to do is use the internet unprotected you may
have heard me talk about what nordvpn can do for
you previously encrypt your internet data and move
your online activity to another location with just
a single click either for security or streaming
all that is still true nor vpn has more than 5
000 servers throughout 60 countries but vpns give
you access to so much more than just new tv shows
like what if you want to buy a video game that's
cheaper somewhere else or maybe not even available
in your country well use nordvpn having trouble
connecting to social media nor vpn want to root
your connection through multiple servers just for
double layered security yes totally possible with
nordvpn right now as a special deal you guys can
get a two-year plan at a huge discount plus one
a bonus gift on top of that or just follow
the link below and now back to today's video
as if the death of his mother was not enough
mozart was rebuffed by alicia whose career was
on an upward trajectory this period was one of the
composer's darkest hours but it also contributed
to developing his maturity on a personal and
professional level for the moment though the
composer needed immediate help thankfully leopold
came to the rescue he secured mozart another post
at the salzburg court in 1779 which in turn
earned him new work in 1718 mozart composed
his best opera so far edomineo king of crete
which attracted the attention of the court in
vienna wolfgang returned to the austrian capital
in 1781 and to save on rent money he lodged with
the webers it was at their home that he met
alessia's sister constans the composer was
smitten he simply had to marry the girl on the one
hand he didn't dare inform his father as leopold
considered the webers below his standing on the
other hand constanza's mother pressured them
to formalize their affair but before tying the
knot moat sad had business to do in july of 1782
he completed one of his most famous operas the
abduction from the cereglio this exotic work set
in the ottoman empire is the first opera in which
mozart left his mark on the plot and characters
he established certain recurring elements such as
the complexity of the female characters who were
better developed than their male counterparts and
the dramatic action never resolving into a fully
positive outcome even offstage the outcome was
not as positive as expected despite the success
in rave reviews mozart received a fee of just 100
guilders not enough to grant financial security
nonetheless wolfgang and constans got married on
the 4th of august in saint stephen's cathedral
in june of 1783 the mozart's welcomed their first
child raymond leopold sadly he died in august the
couple went on to have five more children but
only two survived infancy the grief of losing so
many children weighed on constance already beset
by chronic ulcerated varicose veins wolfgang was
in constant need of cash to pay medical bills
sure but also to sustain a dissolute lifestyle
of partying and drinking that was well beyond
his means thus he plunged into one of his most
productive periods earning 460 guilders in a year
but mozart was still not satisfied he was craving
for new material to compose his next opera
but the narrative of musical conventions at
the time did not provide any exciting inspiration
librettists of the time also complained about the
fact that the musician wanted to meddle in
their realm criticizing and rewriting their
scripts the right occasion arrived when mozart met
lorenzo de ponte librettis who had already worked
for salier the italian court composer may have
held some grudge against the younger rival for
poaching his star librettist but that grudge never
developed into the homicidal hatred portrayed
in theater and film actually solari had a very
good chance to get back at mozart and deponte
in 1786 joseph ii challenged mozart and salieri to
knock their opratic socks off at a special event
a double feature show in which two one-act operas
would be performed back-to-back the audience would
crown their favorite performance mozart's piece
was the impresario a musical comedy about the
production of a musical comedy salieri composed
a more ambitious piece in opera set in the world
of opera so it was all rather meta at the end
of the evening salieri was crowned the winner
by the emperor and the audience so why would he
hold a grudge beyond that in any case salieri was
the most successful and better enumerated of the
two rivals the two respected each other's music
salieri frequently directed mozart's compositions
and was even happy to hand over projects to
wolfgang when he was too busy so mozart and
daponto really needn't worry about salieri
scheming in the shadows the first
collaboration of this dream team is
in our humble opinion mozart's finest work
the marriage of figaro the source material
was a comedy by french playwright beaumarshay
it had a revolutionary subtext as it pits the
commoner figaro against the lustful count of
alma viva mozart and deponte toned down the
anti-aristocratic themes to avoid censorship
but their work was still revolutionary
at least in musical terms and yet the viennese
premiere on may 1 1786 left the audience puzzled
the work was too complex too ahead of its time
but mozart was invited to perform the opera
in prague here the success was phenomenal
the piece remained on stage for three weeks
and mozart was rewarded with a thousand gilders
the prague scene commissioned another opera from
mozart and dupont the don giovanni before it was
completed the earpod mozart died on may 28 1787
throughout his life leopold had been a constant
presence in wolfgang's life he had been his
teacher his manager and even his friend and
confidant it was evident that leopold's influence
was always at risk of becoming overbearing
the father worried genuinely that his son
would squander his talents in later years leopold
was more worried that wolfgang simply squandered
his own fortune as he lived well beyond his means
while wolfgang appreciated leopold's advice he had
actively kept him at a distance to protect his
independence the caboza poured his grief and
unresolved issues into new composition the
unrepentant seducer don juan can be considered
as a proxy for wolfgang the libertine is
eventually dragged to hell by an authoritative
paternal figure the murdered father of one
of his conquests who returns as a ghost
again the reception was terrific and the
play was very good but not good enough
to relieve wolfgang and constance from their
mounting pile of debts not even the long-covered
deployment as an imperial court composer in
december 1787 could help him balancing the books
in 1788 and 1789 the struggling mozart accepted
the help of fellow freemason prince liknowski the
prince organized a tour in dresden and berlin but
the german-speaking world was less appreciative
than czech audiences eventually the prussian
court offered a lucrative fee for a series of
string quartets but as we know these did not come
easy to mozart and he never completed the work the
composer returned to vienna and to constance in
july of 1789 the couple welcomed their fifth child
but the baby girl survived only a
few hours constance fell ill again
and the cost of treatments further
weighed down on the family finances
during these difficult days mozart finally
had a break the emperor himself joseph ii had
commissioned a new opera from him and deponte
cos fantute or thus do they all it premiered
on the 26th of january 1790 but the emperor
was ill with tuberculosis and didn't attend
he died shortly there afterwards succeeded by
his brother leopold ii the pneumonic was less
musically inclined in 1791 mozart could not hope
for patronage from the court with constance being
treated in barden he felt depressed and lonely but
he still had some friends one of them was singer
and freemason brother emmanuel shakineda mozart
and shikoneda thought of dabbling in a popular
genre of the time the magical opera in the german
language the result was the magic flute the opera
outwardly presents itself as a fairy tale but
it is imbued with free masonic symbolism and
humanistic ideals the magic flute premiered on
september 30th 1791 it became a huge success
one alas mozart could not fully enjoy his health
was deteriorating due to rheumatism swelling
fevers and persistent depression moreover it
was just overworked while composing the magic
flute he had to accept the commission for another
opera la clemenza de tito required by leopold ii
for his coronation ceremony mozart took on
a further request by an anonymous messenger
a masked cloaked stranger required mozart
to compose a requiem the music to a funeral
mass wolfgang interpreted this as a sign of
approaching doom he was seriously convinced
he was being poisoned as he wrote in a letter i
know i have to die i write the requiem for myself
by the way the mysterious patron was not antonio
celieri as portrayed in the amadeus play and film
he was an amateur composer count walzeg stupak
who intended to present the requiem as his own
composition and nobody was poisoning mozart to
date there are more than 130 theories and what
exactly was the composer's illness ranging
from mercury poisoning to syphilis a 2009
study found that the mortality of young males in
vienna was well above average in 1791 and 1792.
this may be linked to an epidemic of streptococcal
infection which caused kidney failure so that may
be the cause and it is compatible with mozart's
symptoms by november of 1791 he was confined to
bed feverish swollen and drained of energy his
condition worsened on the evening of december the
4th and he called for the doctor when the position
drew some blood the composer lost consciousness
at 1am on the 5th of december wolfgang amadeus
mozart died age 35 a life cut short too soon
he left behind an unfinished requiem as per
funeral regulations of the time he was buried
with very little ceremony in a grave shared
with four other bodies his final resting place
has never been identified now we feel today that
discussing mozart's legacy is a bit superfluous
what i'd like to do instead is stress again
how wolfgang amadeus mozart achieved apparent
effortless purity and beauty in his music as
albert einstein put it one feels he merely found
it that it has always existed as part of the inner
beauty of the universe waiting to be revealed but
what he achieved he did from a state of constant
practice in a struggle and personal turmoil